[Music]
[Music]
this man is worth $500 and this man's
going to collect he's Jake Cahill and he
lives by amateurs try and take men and
alive
amateurs usually don't make it whether
you're dead or alive you're just a
dollar sign - jake cahill all day long
Thursdays at 8:30 only on NBC hello
everybody this is Alan Kincaid on the
set of the exciting hit NBC and Screen
Gems television series bounty law now if
you think you're seeing double don't
adjust your television sets because well
in a way you are to my right is bounty
law series lead and Jake Cahill himself
Rick Dalton and to my left is Rick stunt
double cliff booth welcome gentlemen and
thanks for taking the time to visit with
us well it's our pleasure huh so Rick
explain to the audience exactly what it
is a stunt double does well actors are
required to do a lot of dangerous stuff
say Jake Cahill gets shot off his horse
now
can I fall off a horse yes I can it's a
have butts that fall off wrong and I and
a suprema wrist or or a twist my ankle
now that can put an undue burden on
production because now maybe I can't
work for a week so cliff here is meant
to help carry the load is that how you
describe your job cliff carrying his
load and spell right
join me next week on the set of the Dick
Van Dyke Show where I'll be talking to
those comical cut-ups Morey Amsterdam
and Rosemarie til then this is Alan
Kincaid signing off from Hollywood
[Music]
[Music]
I wanna tell you what stop
the flower Palestine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
murder revenge and passionate intrigue
burn Alesi stars of the Los Angeles
television premiere of love hate and
dishonours Saturday aside on khj TV 9
her face in the misty light
hello mr. shorter Oh Gina I had a
meeting with a very handsome cowboyed
man he's waiting for you in the bargain
well since I just finished watching a
Rick pop and folk festival I think I
know who you are
put it there it's my pleasure
I mean mr. Schwartz and and and thank
you for taking an interest choice nice
once damn I'm sorry about that
my pleasure mr. Schwartz ami Marvin
Marvin call me Rick Rick Oh
that's your son oh no that's my stunt
double cliff booth
yeah good to meet you we've worked
together since the bless who seizes a
bounty law the cars in the shops and he
gave me a ride that's a big lie Rick got
his driver's license taken away for too
many drunk driving tickets cliff drives
him everywhere
yes I figured good friend but I try I
want to send you greetings from my wife
Mary Alice
we had a Rick Dalton double feature in
our screening last night oh okay
that's both flattering and embarrassing
what you see 35 millimeter prints aft
anna and the 14 fists of McCluskey I
hope the Rick Dalton a double feature
wasn't too painful for you in there and
the missus Oh what are you saying
Mary Alice westerns our whole courtship
we watch mice and we thoroughly enjoyed
denim oh that's anyway she goes to bed I
open up a box of diamonds I light up
myself a cognac and I watch the 14 fists
of Michaelis what a picture
what up thank you good picture yeah
that'd be so much fun
well the shooting I love that stuff you
know they're killing a lot of killem
[Music]